une épaisse fumée noire se dégage de cet
aéroport militaire près de carquif le
site vient d'être touché par des frappes
russes des l'aube en Ukraine des
explosions retentit un peu partout dans
le pays
je viens de vivre le pire réveil de ma
vie à 5h du matin je me suis réveillé et
j'ai entendu des tirs je me suis
précipitée sur le balcon et je me suis
rendu compte qu'il ne s'agissait pas de
feu d'artifice
il y avait des explosions j'ai vu de la
fumée à l'horizon
l'est de l'Ukraine mais aussi Kiev ou
encore Odessa tout le pays a été attaqué
par la Russie qui dit ne visait que des
sites militaires
atchoughev près de carquif les habitants
on constate que ces immeubles ont aussi
été touchés le président volody
mirzelenski a proclamé la loi martiale
et on appelle au volontaire
nous distribuons déjà des armes et nous
continuerons à en distribuer pour
défendre notre pays à tous ceux qui
veulent et qui ont la capacité de
défendre notre souveraineté le futur de
l'Ukraine dépend de chaque citoyen
dans la capitale les sirènes
anti-bombardement longuement résonné ce
matin les gares station de métro ont été
prises d'assaut beaucoup ont aussi pris
la route donnant lieu à ses
embouteillages
à partir de 6h ce matin tout le monde a
commencé à s'activer à tenter de quitter
Kiev mais il y avait énormément de monde
et c'est impossible de fuir l'Ukraine en
ce moment
les files d'attente s'allonge devant les
distributeurs
je pense qu'il n'y aura bientôt plus
d'électricité plus d'eau
ce sera en fait comme en 2014
car ici les troupes russes ne sont qu'à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres après
être rentré ce matin en Ukraine par la
Crimée annexé par la Russie il y a 8 ans
selon Kiev le bilan s'élèverait déjà à
une quarantaine de soldats tués et une
dizaine de civils